[Musik]
seit dem 24 februar blickt die welt mit
anderen augen auf russland dieses
riesige land ist jetzt ein aggressor der
seinen nachbarn überfallen hat und
städte in schutt und asche legt tausende
menschen sind nach angaben der
ukrainischen behörden schon getötet
worden zehn millionen ukrainer sollen
laut der uno auf der flucht sein im
inland und im ausland und was sagt die
russische bevölkerung dazu der
ukrainische präsident wohl oder messi
lenski hat in seinem interview mit
russischen journalisten anfang der woche
noch mal seine bestürzung darüber
ausgedrückt dass viele russen den krieg
unterstützen ist das wirklich so im faz
podcast für deutschland möchte ich heute
eine antwort finden ich habe mit zwei
jungen russen telefoniert ihre heimat
bereits verlassen haben außerdem habe
ich eine russische ballettlehrerin in
ihrem studio in frankfurt besucht sie
setzt sich seit kriegsbeginn für
ukrainische flüchtlinge ein weil sie den
krieg schrecklich findet in ihrer
eigenen familie haben dafür aber nicht
alle verständnis mit meiner kollegin
natalia wenzel warkentin schaue ich mir
an was dahintersteckt wieso sind die
russischen communitys zum teil so
gespalten gerade durch die gruppe der
russlanddeutschen geht ein richtiger
riss sagt natalya wir klären außerdem ob
russen schon anfeindungen wegen ihrer
herkunft erleben heute ist donnerstag
der 31 märz ich bin theresa weiß schön
dass sie dabei sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
viele helfen geflüchteten ukraine auch
menschen mit russischem hintergrund eine
der helferinnen ist anastasia dirksen
bayou die russische ballettlehrerin lebt
seit 2006 in deutschland und leitet eine
ballettschule im frankfurter westen die
räume sind weitläufig und hell in einem
raum hängen kostüme aus buntem stoff ein
kanarienvogel zwitschert manchmal im
hintergrund aber seit einiger zeit wird
er übertönt von den ukrainischen kindern
die vormittags den tanzsaal stürmen
anastasia derksen view bietet ihren
unterricht kostenlos als aktivität für
die flüchtlingskinder an denn als sie
vom krieg erfahren hat wollte sie
unbedingt helfen
schwierig nicht zu erfahren weil
natürlich alle
nachrichten haben gebunden wenn sie aber
in facebook und habe schreckliche bilder
gesehen und ich folge nicht die politik
ich habe keine ahnung von politik ist
besser in meiner ballettwelt
versteckt sozusagen und so fühle mich
hier sicher aber ich habe dann
schreckliche bilder gesehen und ich hab
mein wagen gefragt was sie dort wohnt er
hat gesagt jetzt krieg putin hat krieg
angefangen
und dann habe ich angefangen so ein
bisschen mehr zu schauen was eigentlich
passiert ist
und dann habe ich viele schreckliche
videos gesehen wie in ukraine die häuser
zerbombt waren und die menschen getötet
und so weiter und das war so ersten drei
tage von kriegen das jetzt schon
mittlerweile einen monat her
und ich war schon richtig geschäft
konnte wirklich nichts machen ich kann
ich konnte es einfach nicht glauben dass
heutzutage so was passiert ist und vor
allem russland mit drei ja das ist
einfach unfassbar
weil das kann man einfach nicht
realisiert dass es wahr ist weil
sind gründer und schwester ja als würden
gründer und schwester einander töten das
ist schrecklich
ich war sehr sehr emotional und
dann habe ich gedacht dass ich da
rauskomme ich musste etwas machen sie
engagiert sich seitdem in einer gruppe
von freiwilligen in verschiedenen chats
organisieren die privatleute
medizinische hilfe übersetzungen
rechtsanwälte und auch wohnungen ich
habe nicht so richtung weil manche sagen
okay ich bin am bahnhof
andere sagen ich helfe mit die
wohnungssuche ich habe wirklich alles
ein bisschen kontakt manchen wohnung
gefroren die meisten möbel geworden
anderen
andere begleitet zu krankenhaus oder
arzt gefunden von allem ein bisschen das
fordert allerdings auch seinen tribut
wir machen das schon seit einem monat
und alle haben noch job allerhand
familien und wir sind alle einfach
fertig wir schlafen wenig wir haben vier
kilo oder fünf kilo abgenommen
zwei gibt zum essen ja und wir sind
einfach übermüdet aber wohl trotzdem
helfen ja weil es ist ja
schrecklich einfach ja für die
ballettlehrerin war klar dass sie helfen
will helfen muss weil der krieg
schrecklich ist sie spricht von krieg
obwohl sie einen russischen pass hat und
natürlich auch zugang zu vielen
russischen medien die stellen die
situation in der ukraine ganz anders dar
also meine persönliche erfahrung ist so
dass in russland wird anders gezeigt
und sie kriegen da total anderes bild
und
andere informationen alles anders
umgedreht und das ist sehr sehr traurig
und viele menschen in russland
ich habe auch so ein interview gesehen
der eine reportern ist die straße in
russland gegangen und haben so fragen
gestellt und da hat man gesehen manche
leute die sind wirklich davon überzeugt
was dort erzählt wird das ist sehr sehr
großer propaganda und information wird
richtig gefiltert und gemacht sowie das
dort bekommen ist das ist meine meinung
ist so wie ich das sehe und ich das
mädchen bekomme von hier ja also meine
meinung nach da jetzt wirklich falsches
bild und die leute haben keine
möglichkeit eine rehn vor zu bekommen
das betrifft auch ihre familie in
russland die schaut und hört nämlich
starts funk und glaubt nicht dass
russland ein angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine führt ich versuche darüber nicht
zu reden
ja aber
meine familie zum beispiel wenn ich rede
und ich verstehe die haben anderes bild
wir haben total anderes bild und sie
glauben das nicht sie glauben nicht was
da abgeht und
verstehen es auch nicht wirklich was los
ist das ist auch schwierig weil wenn
informationen nur begrenzt verfügbar ist
dann kann man das auch nicht mitkriegen
ja man kann nicht zum beispiel hier in
deutschland man kann so bilder sehen und
so von zwei seiten man kann so
vergleichen okay aber dort nicht in
russland nicht und jetzt seit einer
woche oder zwei noch noch weniger ist
noch mehr manipuliert ja und ich habe
versucht so ein bisschen apparat zu
erklären zu sagen guckt eure meinung so
aber es gibt noch diese meinung und
die sind zwar sehr unterschiedlich
damit ist bestimmt also wahrheit
bestimmt irgendwo in der mitte
aber es ist nicht komplett sowie euch
erzählt wird und das sehr schlecht
angekommen
dann habe ich gedacht okay ich soll das
nicht so machen
einfach dass wir nicht streiten erstens
und zweitens ist es besser für mich
meine familie dort weil sie leben dort
ja gefährlich für die gefällig
und für mich ist ja sowieso gefallen ist
ich weiß nicht ob ich überhaupt
nichts das heißt nach rosen ablegen darf
ob ich da nicht verhaftet werden oder so
diese aussicht ist sehr bedrückend wie
fühlt sie sich als russe mit den
entwicklungen
ich bin wirklich sehr traurig weil ihr
ich habe wirklich nicht viele verwandte
oder bekannte aber meine familie ist da
trotzdem macht das mich wirklich sehr
traurig meine heimat natürlich ich war
auch nicht so oft da er war zb meine
mutter hier das war aber trotzdem
einfach diese gedanke ich darf nicht hin
dass es schon kannst dass es schon
heftig
anastasia derksen bayou fürchtet
vielleicht nicht mehr in ihre heimat
reisen zu können weil sie über den krieg
spricht ihn auch als solchen benennt und
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine hilft
schauen wir jetzt mal auf die andere
seite russen in russland es ist
vollkommen klar dass die ukraine die
hauptleidtragenden in diesem russischen
angriffskrieg sind in deutschland kommen
jeden tag tausende flüchtlinge an weil
sie die unerträgliche situation der sie
in kharkiv oder mario pohl ausgesetzt
waren nicht mehr ausgehalten haben doch
es gibt noch eine zweite
flüchtlingsbewegung in diesen tagen auch
der ukrainische präsident zielinski hat
das erkannt in seinem interview mit den
russischen journalisten sagte er in
einigen monaten wird jede russische
familie einen verlust zu beklagen haben
sei es direkt durch den krieg oder sei
es weil jemand aus wandere einer davon
ist ilja groß key elia ist ein junger
unternehmer aus sankt petersburg 21
jahre alt er hat das start-up baby mit
gegründet dort bekommen junge russen
nachhilfe für ihre abschlussprüfung das
programm ist ein erfolg zehntausende
nutzer haben es damit schon an die uni
geschafft aber gründer elia hat seine
heimat verlassen er lebt jetzt in berlin
am 4 märz ist er als tourist über
helsinki eingereist er hat mir gesagt
wir können seinen vollen namen hier gern
nennen er plant nämlich nicht zeitnah
nach russland zurück zu kehren
mir gefiel nicht wie sich die dinge in
russland entwickelten ich habe unsere
regierung nicht unterstützt und ich habe
putin nicht unterstützt ich halte ihn
nicht für einen rechtmäßigen präsidenten
schon vor dem 24 februar habe ich
darüber nachgedacht das land in den
nächsten jahren mal zu verlassen nicht
nur aus politischen gründen und auch
nicht weil ich russland nicht mag ich
liebe russland es ist ein tolles land
mit großer geschichte aber ich mag die
regierung nicht ich kann diese dinge
aber eigentlich voneinander trennen
ich wollte weiter in russland leben aber
ich wollte auch ins ausland reisen um
andere sprachen zu lernen und die welt
kennen zu lernen bei kriegsbeginn wurde
mir dann aber klar dass ich alles hat
eine starke repression alle unabhängigen
medien mussten ihre arbeit einstellen
die leute fingen an über kriegsrecht zu
reden das würde bedeuten dass die
grenzen geschlossen werden vor allem für
die männer ich hätte das land also nicht
mehr verlassen können und nicht für eine
kurze zeit
ich habe dann entschieden so schnell wie
möglich zu gehen ich wollte meine jugend
nicht in russland verlieren und auch
meine träume nicht aufgeben müssen
wir einer der ersten gewesen den sie in
die armee eingezogen hätten und ich bin
jung und ich habe nicht gedient er sitzt
jetzt also in berlin und arbeitet weiter
für sein startup im permanenten home
office sozusagen oder er im nord home
office was denkt er über die lage in der
ukraine
ich bin entsetzt ich fühle mich
schrecklich weil ich nichts tun kann
außer
wohltätigkeitsorganisation oder
unabhängige medien in russland zu
unterstützen damit die leute wissen was
wirklich in der ukraine passiert
ich weiß dass menschen sterben und ich
weiß dass russische medien die wahrheit
verstecken sie liegen die russen an die
russen das volk würde das nie
unterstützen
und ich weiß es gibt diskussionen im
westen darüber dass die russen für den
krieg sind weil 70 von ihnen putin
unterstützen
das ist aber falsch sie unterstützen den
krieg nicht sie werden von der regierung
angelogen die leute werden gefragt
unterstützen sie die russische
militärische spezialoperation in der
ukraine mit deren hilfe nazis bekämpft
werden und dann sagen sie ja natürlich
das unterstützen wir das ist eine gute
sache großartiges land dann könnte
warum glaubt er der propaganda nicht
zum teil weil ich zur nächsten
generation in russland gehöre zur
generation z wir haben zugang zu vielen
informationen
wir sind keine fernseh kinder wir haben
zugang zu unterschiedlichen meinungen
aber wenn du erwachsen bist irgendwo
tief in russland und nur starts fähren
sind schaust und nicht einmal weiß dass
instagram existiert dann hast du nur
diese eine
werden noch viele junge gut ausgebildete
leute russland verlassen er kann
natürlich nicht für alle sprechen aber
in seinem umfeld ist die stimmung
eindeutig
[Musik]
meine freunde und bekannten in russland
denken das ist ein desaster für das
ganze land und ihre zukunft wir sind nur
menschen die ein glückliches leben
führen wollten dazu gehört dass wir
reisen und gute jobs bekommen können
oder im ausland studieren
diesen brain drain die abwanderung von
jungen erfolgreichen mehrsprachigen
russen gibt es schon länger denn
repressiv ist das regime in moskau schon
eine zeit lang meine kollegin elena
bayerische war ist darum schon vor
einigen monaten nach deutschland
emigriert ich kenne elena aus einem
journalisten austauschprogramm sie hatte
zuletzt für die deutsche welle in moskau
gearbeitet ich habe sie angerufen
[Musik]
sie ist schon vor einigen monaten
ausgewandert denn die lage für
journalisten hat sich in ihrer heimat
stetig verschlechtert
ich habe russland nicht nach dem
ausbruch des krieges verlassen sondern
ein paar monate vorher als die situation
für journalisten dort schon sehr
schwierig wurde
ich hatte bereits vor zwei jahren
entschieden dass ich wieder nach berlin
will aber ich war noch unsicher dann kam
all die neuen gesetze gegen meinungs-
und redefreiheit in russland
um die gefahr dass mein damaliger
arbeitgeber deutsche welle dort
eingestellt oder zu einem ausländischen
agenten erklärt wurde wir haben das auch
bei anderen freien medien beobachtet
[Musik]
ich war mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher
ob ich als agentin geführt werden wollte
ich war ziemlich geknickt und ich wollte
einfach nur an einem sicheren ort sein
elena hat jetzt in berlin ein studium
aufgenommen wenn es geht will sie aber
wieder in russland arbeiten
ich hoffe wirklich dass ich bald
zurückgehen und darüber berichten kann
das in russland passiert aber ich bin
nicht so mutig ist unter der gefahr zu
tun für 15 jahre ins gefängnis zu müssen
für die willentliche verbreitung von
fake news so nennen sie das jetzt also
nein nicht jetzt so mutig bin ich nicht
ich habe sie gefragt ob sie glaubt dass
noch mehr russische journalisten ihre
heimat verlassen
ich bin überrascht wie viele
journalisten noch in russland sind es
ist falsch zu sagen dass alle das land
verlassen hätten sie haben einfach kein
geld dafür
sie sitzen in ihren wohnungen ohne auch
nur ein wort zu schreiben und sind in
einer schlechten situation
die meisten meiner freunde und meine
familie sind ebenfalls noch dort sie
wollen vielleicht auch gehen aber sie
haben kein geld und keine beziehungen
ins ausland
also ich glaube sie haben fast jede
hoffnung verloren dass alles gut wird
sie versuchen einfach die situation zu
überstehen ihre würde und ihre
überzeugungen zu behalten
es ist eine dunkle zeit für alle das
sagen sie mir und sie alle warten darauf
dass sich die situation ändert und
natürlich sind sie auch gegen diesen
krieg ich habe das glück dass niemand in
meiner familie den krieg unterstützt
oder wie sie es nennen die militärische
spezialoperation
[Musik]
aber wie sollen die russen eigentlich
bescheid wissen wenn es faktisch keine
freien medien mehr gibt er lena sagt wer
will findet informationen
sie haben den zugang nicht vollständig
blockiert man kann vpn kanäle nutzen und
man kann nachrichten auf telegramm lesen
außerdem haben viele menschen in
russland alle verbindungen zur ukraine
über whatsapp sie bekommen die
nachrichten direkt aus erster hand und
natürlich wissen sie daher was dort
passiert also in meinem kreis ich kann
nicht sagen wie das in anderen familien
ist
[Musik]
die beiden russen von denen wir jetzt
gehört haben zeichnen er ein düsteres
bild von den umständen in ihrer heimat
aber wie geht es den menschen mit
russischen wurzeln die schon lange hier
bei uns sind etwa den russlanddeutschen
wie stehen sie zum krieg in der ukraine
viele russlanddeutsche haben auch
ukrainische wurzeln sie seien darum
selbst bestürzt über den krieg das sagt
alwina nazarenus vetter die
geschäftsführerin der
interessengemeinschaft der deutschen aus
russland in hessen die cdu-politikerin
ist auch in anderen gremien der
russlanddeutschen aktiv etwa bei der
landsmannschaft der deutschen aus
russland sie meint die institutionen und
organisationen der russlanddeutschen
können jetzt sogar besonders gut helfen
diese vielfalt um zusammenhalt gehören
einfach zu unseren stärken weshalb wir
unserem jetzt bewahrten strukturen für
unkomplizierte hilfsangebot bezüglich
abrufen können sei das bei den
behördengängen oder bei der betreuung
der kinder jugendlichen also zum
beispiel die deutsche jugend aus
russland hat hier in frankfurt fünf
kitas wir haben in allen unseren kitas
bereits schon geflüchtete kinder
aufgenommen also wir betreuen aber auch
die traumatisierten familien wie gesagt
wie leben genauso wie viele großartige
vereine momentan in deutschland diese
solidarität mit den geflüchteten
menschen vor ist die stimmung da
wirklich so einhellig das kläre ich
jetzt mit einer kollegin die sich da gut
auskennt
[Musik]
bei mir im studio ist jetzt mal eine
kollegin natalia wenzel war kennt ihn
natalya du beschäftigst dich bei uns in
der faz immer wieder auch mit
migrantischen themen und zuletzt hast du
dir auch die situation für die
russlanddeutschen angeschaut vielleicht
kannst du zuerst mal kurz erzählen was
ist das überhaupt für eine gruppe
russlanddeutscher ist eine bezeichnung
für die nachfahren von menschen die im
achtzehnten jahrhundert ins russische
reich ausgereist sind damals auf
einladung der zarin und überwiegend in
den 90er jahren zurück nach deutschland
gekommen sind sind gab auch schon welche
in den achtzigern es gab auch welche
noch in den 2000 dann aber der höhepunkt
der migration war in den 90er jahren und
das sind nicht nur das ist wichtig zu
wissen auch wenn ich sie
russlanddeutschen endete nicht nur
menschen die aus dem heutigen russland
kommen sondern die können auch aus
kasachstan kommen oder aus der ukraine
menschen aus dem russischsprachigen
bereich und aus dem ehemaligen
russischen reich die wieder nach
deutschland gekommen also viele von
diesen menschen haben einen irgendwie
gearteten russischen hintergrund weil
sie vielleicht mal dort gelebt haben
oder die eltern und jetzt sollen die
sich plötzlich auch häufig irgendwie
positionieren also sie werden ja gefragt
von verschiedenen medien auch von uns
wie sie jetzt zum krieg in der ukraine
stehen wie sie mit der situation umgehen
und du hast bei seinen recherchen
festgestellt es gibt gar nicht so die
eine position sondern da gibt es
ziemlich unterschiedliche ansichten
genau ist es wichtig zu wissen dass sie
auch deshalb befragt werden weil sie
eine sehr sehr große gruppe und die
amerikanischen gruppen in deutschland
ausmachen also man geht ungefähr von 3,5
millionen menschen mit diesem
hintergrund aus und deutschland und bei
meinen recherchen habe ich festgestellt
dass es einen großen konflikt zwischen
den generationen gibt also dass wir eine
generation haben die in der ehemaligen
sowjetunion
aufgewachsen ist nun in deutschland lebt
und dem krieg durchaus ja im positiver
eingestellt das gegenüber als die
generation die entweder sehr jung
hierher gekommen ist oder komplett hier
aufgewachsen ist und die eine sehr sehr
kritische meinung dazu hat und auf der
seite der ukraine steht und dieser
konflikt belastet gerade sehr sehr viele
familien
belastet dieser konflikt wir haben viele
ältere menschen die leider auf die
propaganda des kreml reinfallen das
nicht man einfach so sagen wir haben
menschen die russische staatsfernsehen
konsumieren aber auch soziale netzwerke
plattformen die upper class niki das ist
in russische äquivalent zu facebook
spielen eine ganz ganz große rolle in
der aktuellen situation da werden
einfach gezielt propaganda
falschinformation verbreitet
videomaterial bildmaterial ohne jegliche
quellenangaben das wird weiter
verschickt das findet den weg in
familien whatsapp gruppen ja man muss
wissen diese menschen sind oft sehr sehr
eng miteinander vernetzt auch
die digitalen möglichkeiten und wir
haben diese menschen auf der einen seite
und wir haben ihre kinder die ihnen
widersprechen und die dann am esstisch
mit ihnen diskutieren und auch geschockt
sind und nicht begreifen können wie ihre
familie oder ihre eltern ihre onkels und
tanten
ernsthaft diesen krieg gutheißen können
da da die werte gehen so stark
auseinander und da findet so eine
desillusionierung auf seiten der
kinderstadt die sagen ich habe so viele
gute werte von meiner familie
mitbekommen wie kann es sein dass ihr
einen krieg bei dem unschuldige menschen
getötet werden gut heißen könnte aber es
scheint dass er dann über völlig
verschiedene dinge reden oder eben eine
ganz unterschiedliche basis haben auf
der sie sich ihre meinung gebildet haben
ja und oft sind diese menschen die auch
ihre information hauptsächlich von
diesen plattformen oder auch vom aus dem
russischen staatsfernsehen konsumieren
beziehungsweise ziehen nicht mehr
zugänglich für sachliche argumente ich
habe auch mit vielen gesprochen die
immer wieder versuchen ins gespräch zu
gehen mit ihren familien und sagen ich
habe hier die belege dafür dass das was
du sagst nicht stimmt hier sind die
beweise aber sie sind überhaupt nicht
zugänglich es wird alles oftmals
abgewatscht mit nein das stimmt nicht
ich habe recht du kannst es nicht wissen
denn du glaubst der westlichen pro pack
auch das haben wir oft dass die menschen
sehr einseitig sich nur informieren und
und alles was bei uns
vermittelt wird nicht glauben ja ich
habe über das thema auch mit einem
gesprächspartner aus russland gesprochen
er ist ein junger unternehmer aus und
petersburg heißt er ja und er ist total
überzeugt davon dass kein russe degen
krieg unterstützen würde wenn die
wahrheit bekannt werde
die menschen in russland wollen den
krieg nicht sie werden an gelungen sie
unterstützen das gute die militärische
spezialoperation gegen nazis sie kennen
die wahrheit nicht wenn sie es täten
wären sie dann
trotzdem sagen uns ja umfragen dass
ziemlich viele russen das doch irgendwie
tun was denkst du was macht das mit
familienvan da ebenso unterschiedliche
meinungen vertreten sind und zum
beispiel ein kind sogar sagt ich gehe
weg aus dem land
es ist schmerzhaft vereinigen es sind es
ist ein sehr schmerzhafter konflikt eben
weil sie nicht dieselbe basis haben ich
stimme ihm zu und er sagt es ja auch
schon wenn sie die wahrheit wüssten aber
die negative der in anführungszeichen
entnazifizierung der ukraine und
entmilitarisierung die sind so weit
verbreitet dass das ja im grunde
sachliches argumentieren mit vielen
menschen die dafür zugänglich sind
überhaupt nicht möglich ist und das ist
ein sehr schmerzhafter konflikt der in
die familien getragen wird und diese
familien mitunter auch entzweien kann
ich habe für eine recherche in einer
familie gesprochen mit einem
geschwisterpaar bruder und schwester in
den dreißigern die jetzt im zuge des
krieges im grunde komplett mit ihrer
familie gebrochen haben mit ihrem vater
gebrochen haben der ihn immer wieder
material zugespielt hat schau dir das
doch mal an es kann doch nicht wahr sein
und die immer fassungsloser wurden und
immer ratloser wurden und die sich im
grunde nicht anders zu helfen wusste als
zu sagen es tut mir leid wir müssen an
diesem punkt den kontakt abbrechen weil
ich wir können nicht mehr mit dir'
diskutieren und es kommt dann schnell
auch auf eine sehr emotionale ebene der
der vater hat dann den den satz fallen
lassen gegenüber dem sohn du tust mir
leid du tust mir leid dass du die
westliche propaganda glaubst und das ist
so eine geringschätzung und herr
abschätzung in den in den positionen
aller beteiligten das dann überhaupt gar
keine grundlage mehr besteht irgendwie
wertschätzend miteinander zu reden und
das ist sehr schmerzhaft das kann ich
mir vorstellen diesen text für den du
das recherchiert hast ihn können wir am
sonntag in der sonntagszeitung leben
richtig gesagt ja vor kurzem hast du
aber auch noch über ein anderes phänomen
geschrieben und zwar die diskriminierung
von russen am arbeitsplatz und das
phänomen antiislamismus schon in dem
text mit seinem kollegen über die
russlanddeutschen klang das thema schon
mal an da regten sie einige männer
darüber auf dass ein gastwirt keine
russischstämmigen oder russischen
menschen mehr bedienen möchte und ich
frage mich denkst du das thema wird uns
jetzt häufiger begegnen
durchaus aber es ist ganz wichtig dass
wir uns diese fälle und diese meldungen
ganz ganz differenziert anschauen und
ganz genau hinschauen ist das wirklich
ein vorfall dingen als anti islamismus
als als feindlichkeit gegenüber
als als russen oder slawen gelesenen
menschen bezeichnen kann oder haben wir
vielleicht ganz andere sachen eine rolle
gespielt also ich glaube wir werden in
zukunft immer wieder über diese fälle
stolpern aber ist es wichtig dass wir da
sehr differenziert rutschen ja ich habe
auch meine anderen gesprächspartner aus
russland gefragt wie es ihnen geht was
sie bisher so erlebt haben und wir
können uns einmal kurz anhören was ihr
ja dazu gesagt hat
ich habe keine diskriminierung erfahren
mir wurde gesagt dass es passieren
könnte
wenn mir jemand sagen würde große zu
sein ist etwas schlechtes würde ich es
verstehen ich unterstütze die regierung
ja nicht würde sagen es tut mir leid was
man tut
ich habe auch elena noch gefragt dass es
einen journalisten kollegin von uns und
sie hat mir folgendes erzählt
um es kurz und knapp zu sagen ich war
vorbereitet ich habe eine negative
reaktion erwartet aber haben alle
bekommen
alle meine freunde und verwandten aus
russland fragen mich die ganze zeit
allen geht es dir gut behandeln sie dich
gut ich bin davon immer überrascht sie
denken ich bin in einer schlechteren
lage als sie in russland aktuell ich
erkläre dann immer nein ich erlebe keine
ablehnung alle behandeln mich wirklich
gut viele meiner deutschen freunde und
auch die von anderswo haben mir sehr
liebe nachrichten geschrieben
also die beiden haben keine solchen
erlebnisse gehabt was er erst mal schön
das aber gewappnet haben sie sich dafür
irgendwie schon im vorhinein ja das habe
ich auch und ich kann ganz ähnlich wie
die beiden berichten dass aus dem umfeld
er nachfragen kommen hey bist du okay
wie geht es dir damit hast du vielleicht
auch noch familie in russland oder der
ukraine wie indesign betrifft ist eine
familie das ist super dass es so ist ich
habe für diese recherche in der es um
anti islamismus am arbeitsplatz ging
ungefähr mit zehn elf zwölf menschen
gesprochen über dieses thema menschen
die mir vorfälle zurückgemeldet haben
und es hat sich ganz klar
herauskristallisiert dass das
hauptsächlich vorfälle waren in
bereichen wo menschen sehr engen kontakt
haben zur breiten bevölkerung also nicht
innerhalb ihrer kollegen schafft
innerhalb ihres teams innerhalb ihres
unternehmens von vorgesetzten oder den
kollegen das sind alles noch einzelfälle
und es ist wichtig dabei wie ich schon
anfangs gesagt habe sehr differenziert
drauf zu schauen die situation genau zu
analysieren und sich zu fragen ist das
wirklich jetzt passiert weil ich
russisch gelesen werden oder weil man
wie man einen russischen background
zuschreibt und ist das jetzt aufgrund
von
stickmaschinen diese situation oder hab
ich sie vielleicht anders interpretieren
die emotionalität bei diesen vorfällen
macht es dann immer sehr schwer
diskriminierungserfahrungen sind
natürlich sehr sehr schmerzhaft und
deshalb verliert man das schnelle
objektiven blickwinkel aber ist es
wichtig diese situation zu analysieren
um auch nicht einer in eine falle zu
tappen die auch der kreml bewusst stellt
ja indem
das narrativ des in anführungszeichen
russen westens führt der russen und
russen bewusst diskriminiert und
der käme die menschen so auf seine seite
zieht ich habe für diese recherche mit
einem juristen und anti diskriminierungs
trainer sergej prokop kann ließ er
gesprochen der sich schon sehr lange mit
anti islamismus beschäftigt und er auch
eigens eine meldestelle eingerichtet hat
also der versucht hat diese ganzen
informationen und meldungen die jetzt
gerade völlig ungefiltert über die
verschiedenen plattformen kommen erstmal
zu sammeln und aufzuarbeiten und er hat
mir bestätigt dass es einfach extrem
wichtig ist die situation genau zu
beleuchten um halt da nicht in diese
falle zu tappen und das narrativ von
brüssel vom westen zu bedienen
das habe ich auch von anderer seite
gehört nämlich von alpina nazarenus
vetter die in einigen gremien der
russlanddeutschen aktives diese fälle
die diskriminierung und ausgrenzung
aufgrund der herkunft der sprache der
ethnischen zugehörigkeit gibt es
tatsächlich und wir nehmen jede meldung
irgend und verweisen dann die landsleute
auf die einschlägige beratungsstellen
wichtig ist einfach dass die menschen
wissen dass der deutsche rechtsstaat sie
beschützt und man sie nicht im stich
lässt wir appellieren an die hiesige
bevölkerung nicht putins krieg nach
deutschland zu holen denn damit spielen
wir in ihm in die hände er möchte dass
der westen das stabilisiert ist und
dabei sind ihm auch alle mittel recht
man muss wissen was hinter sehr vielen
meldungen gerade in social media sich
falschmeldungen verbergen deswegen
appelliere auch an unserer landsleute
immer ganz genau hinzuschauen nicht
hysterisch zu werden und putins
propaganda nicht auf den leim zu gehen
ich kann der frauenarzt linus vetter da
nur zustimmen diese empörung bricht
leicht vom zaun wenn eine solche videos
solches bildmaterial zugesendet wird man
neigt dazu leicht dann in diese falle zu
geraten eben weil viele auch
schmerzhafte erinnerung haben an
ähnliche vorfälle vor allen dingen in
den 90er jahren damals war die stimmung
gegenüber der russlanddeutschen nicht
unbedingt eine gute und viele haben
solche erfahrung von seiten der
mehrheitsgesellschaft gemacht und das
weckt einfach unschöne erinnerungen und
man ist leicht geneigt wieder in diese
in diese falle zu tappen und in diesem
schmerz den mann damals gefühlt hat aber
wir treten sehr sehr gut daran diese
situation sehr differenziert zu
betrachten und genau zu analysieren ich
finde das haben wir jetzt mit deiner
hilfe auch echt geschafft vielen vielen
dank dass du hier mit uns gesprochen
hast für deine einblicke und eine
expertise bei diesem thema sehr gerne
vielen dank
[Musik]
dieser krieg ist auch ein
informationskrieg dass es in dieser
sendung noch einmal deutlich geworden er
zerreißt familie näher bringt russen
dazu zu emigrieren und doch sind
wahrscheinlich in russland selbst sehr
viele menschen davon überzeugt dass
putin ein hehres ziel verfolgt zu lasten
der ukraine für mich ist es ein kleiner
trost dass es trotzdem sehr viele
menschen gibt die den flüchtlingen hier
helfen ganz unabhängig von ihrer eigenen
nationalität das war der faz podcast für
deutschland heute am 31 märz mit theresa
weiß ich bedanke mich für die
unterstützung bei der heutigen folge
ganz besonders bei meinem kollegen tim
neumann der einige der o töne für uns
angefangen hat morgen ist mein kollege
andreas chrobok dann wieder für sie da
machen sie es gut packer
[Musik]